sind allerhöchste Zeit vielen Dank für
das Guru dafür fühle ich mich noch ein
bisschen zu jung
ich bin ein Empfehlungsgeber zum Thema
Gesundheit es wird höchste Zeit auch
über das vierte g zu sprechen vielleicht
ein bisschen zu spät aber nach der
Pandemie ist vor der Pandemie die 3GS
geimpft genesen getestet haben uns drei
Jahre lang beschäftigt es hat dazu
beigetragen dass wir im schlechtesten
Gesundheitszustand sind indem er jemals
gewesen sind insbesondere die Kinder
machen wir da ganz große Sorgen was da
wortwörtlich noch auf uns zurück an
zukünftigen Kosten und Problemen das
macht man sich gar nicht ausmalen es
wird höchste Zeit dass wir dieses Thema
auch politisch ernsthaft angehen
wenn das gerade gesagt die Kinder das
ist noch meine besonderer Punkt darüber
sprechen wir auch ganz viel hier in
dieser Sendung zunächst möchte ich aber
mal auf uns alle kommen ich habe das
gerade angesprochen wir haben viel
gelitten Corona hat deutliches Spuren
bei uns in der Gesellschaft hinterlassen
von ganz drastischen bis anderen die wir
vielleicht auch leichter umdrehen können
ist es uns so ein bisschen auch zur
Gewohnheit geworden sondern Couchpotato
zu war zu werden und dieser Gewohnheit
auch hinzugeben ja wir sind ja
eigentlich grundsätzlich von Natur aus
nicht faul wir sind ökonomisch veranlagt
man darf nie vergessen dass sie nicht
hat sich über Millionen von Jahren
entwickelt und da war natürlich die
Kalorienbilanz in meinem maßgebliches
Thema jetzt haben wir seit wenigen
Jahrzehnten auch nur in den
Industrienationen einen gigantischen
Kalorien Überfluss eine Industrie die
genau an diesen uralten Programm
herumtriggert dass wir eben mehr essen
als wir eigentlich verbrauchen dann sind
sie auch noch deutlich nährstoffärmer
was eine Nährstoffe erzeugt und dann
versuchen wir eben dem gegenzulenken mit
irgendwelchen Kalorien reduzierten
Diäten aber die Eltern sind nichts
anderes als eine simulierte Hungersnot
und kognitiv können wir da vielleicht
zwei drei Wochen mit viel Willenskraft
durchhalten aber irgendwann ist die
erledigt weil die Willenskraft begrenzt
ist und für alltägliche
Herausforderungen Berufsleben
Privatleben ebenfalls investiert werden
muss und dann versagen wir an dieser
Diät logischerweise und das sorgt dafür
dass wir uns wieder einmal schlecht
fühlen und uns selbst einreden wir
hätten keine Disziplin dabei was eine
völlig falsche Herangehensweise an
dieses Gewohnheit veränderungsthema
bleiben wir einmal auch beim Thema
Übergewicht denn da kommt man ja
besonders schwer auch raus genau eben
auch aus dem Grund den sie gerade dieses
diesen Kreislauf den sie gerade
beschrieben haben und viele Menschen
adiposita ist großes Thema in
Deutschland auch in Österreich dort
quasi die dicksten Menschen in Europa
wie gefährlich ist das denn für den
Körper paar Kilo zu viel gehen ab wann
wird es gefährlich ja ein bisschen
flauschiger zu sein schade bestimmt
niemandem aber wenn es dann wirklich
darum geht wenn wir übergewichtig sind
in Kombination mit einem grundsätzlich
schlechten Lebensstil aus schlechte
Ernährung vitalstoffarm plus wenig
Bewegung dann summiert sich dieses
Problem mit dem Eltern werden immer mehr
wir kommen immer mehr in diese lethagie
rein in diese veränderungs Liter gehen
und dann kommt eben ja das Alter mit
dazu und das sorgt dafür dass wir eben
uns da gar nicht mehr richtig
herausbringen können aber eben auch
getriggert durch diese ganzen Diäten die
immer wieder angeboten werden ja gar
nicht funktionieren können weil sie zu
viel auf einmal auf einen Schlag
verändern wollen die Menschen sind auch
völlig verwirrt was ist eigentlich
gesunde Ernährung da passt auch der
Spruch er stieg auf sein Pferd und ritt
in alle Richtungen davon und die Leute
sind völlig verzweifelt was ist richtig
was ist falsch dann kommt da Veganismus
oder paleurernährung und der andere
macht es makrobiotisch dabei ist
erlösungsansatz tatsächlich total
einfach und wenn ich eine gesunde
Ernährung auf einen einzigen Satz
reduzieren möchte dann wäre das man
sollte 80% von dem was man einkauft das
was im Einkaufswagen liegt das sollten
Lebensmittel sein die keine Zutatenliste
tragen die keine Zutaten also das heißt
Obst Gemüse das ist ja das Standard
beispielsweise hochwertige Milchprodukte
oder eben dann Hülsenfrüchte
beispielsweise ein gutes Stück Fleisch
und hochwertiges Stück Fleisch
vielleicht nicht so wie heute heute
essen die Menschen jetzt in letzter Zeit
nicht mehr ganz so viel auch
preisbedingt aber früher war es so
morgens Wurst mittags Fleisch abends
Fleischwurst und das kann auf Dauer
natürlich nicht gesund sein und dann
noch die Qualität mit dazu gesunde
Ernährung ist viel einfacher als man
denkt aber die um Verletzung das ist die
große Herausforderung und ich arbeite
hier auch sehr gerne mit meiner
Community mit dem Prinzip des
schweinehundeschulentages das heißt man
nimmt sich einen einzigen Tag in der
Woche und das ist der persönliche
Gesundheitstag und in diesem einen Tag
halte ich mich eben an bestimmte
Ernährungsregeln und wenn man diesen Tag
Woche für Woche wiederholt dann merken
wir sehr bald wie gewöhnlicher wird wie
gut er einem tut und auf der unbewussten
Ebene werden wir automatisch dann die
Verhaltensweisen aus diesem Schweinehund
schulentag mit in einige andere Tage
übernehmen ohne uns bewusst darum
kümmern zu müssen das heißt frei von
Willenskraft und damit setzen wir
sozusagen die alten Gewohnheiten unter
Druck und ersetzen sie ganz langsam
durch neue das einzige was hier das
Problem ist wir brauchen etwas Geduld
dazu und das sind ja meist ganz schlecht
alle möchten schlank sein und gesund
sein aber keiner möchte werden
gerade gesagt was bringt das alles vor
keine kennen Sie das auch ich kenne
diesen einen Tag den kennt man sonst so
da darf man essen was man will oder
ansonsten gesund zu sein sie drehen das
Prinzip quasi um das Cheat days und sagt
probieren wir doch erstmal an einem Tag
so richtig richtig gesund zu sein da ist
ich habe als als Mutter habe ich ja
quasi noch mal irgendwie vier Kinder
großziehen müssen und mich durchgekämpft
Kindern gesunde Ernährung beizubringen
da hat man ja noch mal quasi nicht nur
die Verantwortung für sich selber wobei
alle vor dem Fernseher zu liegen und
Chips zu essen aber das wird dann aber
auch bewusst gemacht ne also dass man
sagt so äh Chips gibt es quasi nur da
das ist kein Alltagsessen äh süße
Getränke gibt es nur zu besonderen
Gelegenheiten und nicht als Alltagsessen
weil ja irgendwie mittags gibt's halt
Wasser zu trinken Punkt so ne und ähm es
ist schwer sozusagen Kinder in so eine
gesunde Ernährung hineinzugang es ist
ein Kampf und deswegen verstehe ich auch
das ganz viele Leute die nicht kämpfen
weil es viel einfacher ist ja weil es
natürlich viel einfacher ist quasi den
Kindern nur das vorzusetzen was sie was
sie gerne essen
anstatt sie daran zu gewöhnen auch all
die Dinge zu essen die gut für Sie sind
und
ich habe auch mittlerweile muss ich
sagen Nudeln mit parmesaner ist
vollwertige für meine Kinder anerkannt
aber die Regierung
ja aber muss das sein die Regierung
vielleicht schon wieder ganz anders
zumindest versuchen Sie jetzt was zu tun
schauen wir mal rein was die
koalitionskollegen sofort
ein kindergerichtete Werbung trägt
täglich sehr stark in den Alltag von
Kindern ein bisschen ins Kinderzimmer
und während wir wissen dass Kinder bei
diese Werbung besonders empfänglich sind
ist es im Moment so dass 92 Prozent
dieser Werbung die Kinder im Internet
entfernt sind wahrnehmen für Süßigkeiten
Snacks und Fastfood für ungesundes Essen
ist wir müssen verhindern dass das
langfristigen Einfluss auf die Kinder
hat und da wie Landwirtschaftsminister
Chev Özdemir klare Regeln schaffen und
da dafür heute einen Vorschlag vorgelegt
so und der Vorschlag heißt keine Werbung
mehr für ungesundes Essen Süßigkeiten
Chips und so weiter das soll nicht in
der Nähe von Schulen hängen damit die
Kinder dann auf die Idee kommen diesen
Kram auch noch zu essen Herr Herbst ist
das eine gute Idee tragen Sie die Idee
des Koalitionspartners mit keine Werbung
mehr für Süßigkeiten Chips für ungesunde
Quatsch ehrlich gesagt weil auch nicht
der vierjährige entscheidet welche
Süßigkeiten erkauft ich glaube das
machen immer noch die Eltern und die
haben die individuelle Verantwortung und
ich glaube das sollte auch bleiben der
Staat kann nicht die individuelle
Verantwortung der Eltern ersetzen und er
sollte es sich auch nicht anmaßen es ist
auch dieses
ein wir wollen irgendwas nicht wir
verbieten es den Menschen
auch wenn die Werbung nicht mehr ist
also die falsche Herangehensweise man
muss lernen man muss lernen auch Kinder
müssen lernen damit umzugehen dass sie
dass sie umgeben sind von von tollen
großartigen Dingen die sie aber im
eigenen Interesse lernen müssen
vernünftig zu konsumieren das ist das
eine es erinnert mich so ein bisschen
irgendwie an unsere Nachbarn früher die
ihren Kindern das Fernsehen verboten
haben bei uns gibt's kein Fernseher
Nachmittag da ja das heißt diese Kinder
haben gar keinen vernünftigen Fernsehen
Konsum gelernt ja nicht gelernt
auszuschalten sondern die sind quasi sie
haben sich Fernseher gesucht weil ihre
Eltern es verboten haben und ungefähr so
kommen die Grünen vor die alles
verbieten wollen aber Drogen
leckerlisieren wollen was wahrscheinlich
der Ausgleich sein soll dann für uns als
Bürger damit wir das irgendwie so
richtig wahrnehmen dieser Traum Zucker
zu verbieten den hat Frau Kühnast schon
als Umweltministerin getragen die hier
geträumte hier nämlich das auch sie
schon Zucker verbieten wollte und all
diese Dinge
auch Nahrungsergänzung reglementiert
dabei sind die schon ziemlich gut
reglementiert und wenn man sich da
wirklich an die EU-Richtlinien halten
würde dann würden hier viele höhere
Dosierung zugelassen werden also ich
verstehe auch nicht wo diese
Selbstverständnis der Grünen herkommt
gerade beim Thema gesunde Ernährung also
da liegt ganz viel im Magen das mit dem
Verbot sehe ich genauso es bleibt an den
Eltern hängen nur die Eltern stehen auch
wegen diesen ganzen auch finanziellen
Situationen so unter Druck dass die auch
abends gar keine Kraft mehr haben den
Kindern eben auch eine gesunde Ernährung
vorzuleben abends ist man dann völlig
ausgeliefert den Gewohnheiten die sich
im jungen Alter drauf trainiert hat wo
es aber noch überhaupt nichts gemacht
hat weil der Körper kann unglaublich
viel kompensieren aber dann heißt es
jenseits der 30 40 50 da ging es dann
los mit den Krankheiten weil der Körper
eben nicht mehr kompensieren kann das
heißt sie Gewohnheiten die wir uns früh
aneignen neben der mit ins
Erwachsenenalter und da machen sie erst
Probleme und deshalb noch mal diese
Plädoyer für diesen einen Schweinehunde
darum Erfahrungen zusammen Ernährung ist
leichter als man denkt wenn Sie das Ende
so ein vorgeschlagenes Verbot die Kinder
davor schützt oder in ein anderes Denken
bringen könnte dass sie sagen ach so
jetzt sehe ich weniger Süßigkeiten also
will ich sie weniger glauben Sie das ist
der richtige Weg nein ich will nicht
sagen ist Schwachsinn aus dem Augen aus
dem Sinn passt da nicht ganz genau es
wäre natürlich schön wenn man auf der
anderen Seite eben auch mal ja Obst und
Gemüse etwas sexierer verkaufen könnte
dafür Werbung machen könnte
beispielsweise da steht aber keine Lobby
dahinter und das ist das Problem essen
sie denn auch manchmal so ein paar
fettriechenden und danach ja natürlich
beruhigt mich sehr dass es noch möglich
ist alles andere
ich brauche kein Cheat day weil ich
könnte mir das einfach genieße es und
bei mir ist es schon automatisiert gibt
seine ausgleichsstrategie da denke ich
auch nicht mehr drüber nach wenn ich
also mein Abend komplett kalorisch
eskaliere als ein Kalorien Inferno
feiere so viel essen da rein bis der
Magen mit dem Tetris spielen muss dann
gleich am nächsten Tag automatisch
wieder aus und esse ich eben Salat oder
Gemüsepfanne oder irgendwas anderes was
eben dann weniger Kalorien hat und wenn
man sich das angewöhnt hat dann braucht
es auch keine Willenskraft mehr genau
schaffen sich das anzubauen würde pro
Woche ein Tag pro Woche muss man zur
Lachen ein bisschen sagen sich naja
könnt ihr euch welche mein Kühlschrank
Blicke oder ist da genau das drin was
wir gerade
muss ich mal überlegen wie ich das
umsetze ich bin noch so etwas Corona
geschädigt das heißt ich ging zum
Beispiel dreimal in Sport vor Corona
Corona war Pause und danach schaffe ich
jetzt gerade einmal weil ich angeblich
nicht mehr die Zeit habe vorher hatte
ich die Zeit ich habe das eingeplant ich
hatte also genau meine Tage wo ich weit
ging jetzt hinterher habe ich mit mir
und Not komme ich jetzt zu einem Tag ja
und ähm ich weiß es selber und ich
kämpfe mit mir selber ja und sage du
musst eigentlich ja aber der
Schweinehund überwiegt manchmal oder
öfter ist doch bei mir noch hier das
Schwein und eine ganz wichtige Aufgabe
der beschützt nämlich diese
ursprünglichen Energiesparprogramme bzw
er verteidigt die Gewohnheiten die wir
uns über Jahrzehnte auf die biologische
Festplatte gespielt haben gegen
geschwollen und zu kämpfen ist ein
kompletter Fehler wir müssen ihnen zu
unserem Verbündeten machen deswegen sage
ich auch schweinehundeschule ein Tag pro
Woche ich meine da macht er auch mit das
sagt er ja kommt es einen Tag morgen
kann ich wieder Burger essen
aber da kriegt damit alles tut uns
irgendwie ganz gut und daraus entsteht
eine eine intrinsische Motivation das
tut mir so gut aber dann mache ich halt
eben doch mal wieder einen Tag mehr
Sport als bisher das ist auch mit Sport
finde ich hat das genau dieselbe Wirkung
auch also wenn man z.B irgendwie läuft
ja die und wenn man anfängt zu laufen zu
joggen irgendwie dann ist das ein Elend
in der Regel die ersten Tage das heißt
du die ersten zwei drei Male muss man
sich im Prinzip durchkämpfen und dann
passieren Dinge ich hätte es nie für
Möglichkeiten wenn ich das nicht selber
erlebt hätte genau wie sie quasi wie man
quasi in so einem heizzustandgerät
eine Stunde am Stück laufen und denkt
wie schaffe ich das überhaupt weil
tatsächlich der Körper plötzlich
Euphorie empfindet beim Laufen jetzt
muss ich hier als Experte ganz kurz rein
weil viele jetzt genau das weil viele
denken
euphorienerlebnis nach dem Laufenden
nie wieder und deswegen sage ich das
Prinzip des minimalziels das heißt wenn
man überhaupt nicht läuft sagt man okay
ich gehe jetzt einfach mal dreimal die
Woche oder auch jeden Abend zwei Minuten
vor die Haustür mehr nicht eine Minute
in die eine Minute zurück sag hey das
habe ich geschafft ich beweise mir
selber ich kann das ich stehe zu mir zu
dem was ich mir vornehme in der Woche
zwei macht mir eben dann vier Minuten
zwei hin zwei zurück und das wird immer
mehr ausgebaut und auch nie auf Kampf
oder mit Krampf weil das geht auch
schief lieber zu wenig Tempo aber das
konsequent durchziehen und dann kriegt
man dieses Gefühl für das tut mir gut
und dann macht man es automatisch weiter
wurden sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie